hi my name is Kirsten and I'm here to
talk to you about how everything is
connected many of us use the internet
every day but have you actually thought
about how the information travels from
one place to another well the internet
is a series of computers that are
connected via network of cables kind of
like the one that I'm holding right here
this is an Ethernet cable and many of
you have probably used it to connect
your desktop to the Ethernet port law
now this network of cable spans across
continents so for example you might have
a cable running from boston to san
francisco to seattle and then to other
cities in between allowing us to
communicate with computers all across
the country but actually what's more
interesting is that we have cables that
allow us to connect to cities in
different continents and these cables
actually spend oceans these underwater
cables are actually pretty thick there
are two and a half inches in diameter
and they consist of rings of insulation
and shielding which all surround and
inner core of fiber-optic cables now
these fiber optic cables look like these
their class wires and the information is
actually transmitted via lasers so all
of this insulation is protecting these
fiber optic cables which allow your
information to safely travel from one
place to another underneath the water so
the next time you try and visit a
website from another country just take
some time to think about how far the
information to travel to get to your
computer